Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Jetzt seid ihr beiden also OpenData Aktivisten. Ich werde noch was von, wie gesagt, Open Knowledge Foundation, da gibt es irgendwas. Also wenn ich jetzt diese Stunde schon gehört habe, denke ich so, geile Idee, da will ich mitmachen. Was gibt es denn für Organisationen? Also wer ist das da noch, der sich darum kümmert?
Es gibt eine ganze große Zahl von Organisationen, die sich darum kümmern. Also das Open Data Network ist glaube ich so der zentrale Sammelpunkt für Leute in Deutschland, die sich dafür interessieren. Da gibt es die Seite eben opendatanetwork.org und eine Mailing-Liste, auf die man sich anmelden kann, wo man dann so grob mitbekommen, was läuft. Die Open Knowledge Foundation ist eine Organisation, die zuerst in England gegründet wurde und die eben ganz speziell sich mit Einzelprojekten befasst. Also viel Datenkatalogen, das kann man vielleicht nur kurz nachher erklären, und mit Finanztransparenzprojekten, aber auch mit freiem Wissen allgemeiner als zum Beispiel Literatur, die aus dem Urheberrecht rausgefallen ist, irgendwie ordentlich aufzufangen, wissenschaftliche Daten irgendwie vernünftig zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Also man kann also sagen, dass die Open-Out-Fundation sich ein bisschen mehr auch um die, letztlich die Infrastruktur kümmert, was offenes Wissen angeht.
Wie sich das besitzt, ist es ja so, diese offene Datenidee, da gibt es sozusagen Gegner, die aber fast schon klassischerweise dann sagen, wir haben was zu verbergen, wir sind dagegen irgendwie, weil uns das schadet. Aber generell scheint das eine Idee zu sein, die irgendwie wohl gelitten ist, aber die deshalb irgendwie nicht großzeitig umgesetzt wird, weil so, naja, wir haben eigentlich gerade ein wichtigeres zu tun. Also so kommt es gerade rüber.
Nee, nicht wichtigeres zu tun, sondern wir haben A, keine Ahnung, wo fangen wir jetzt an? Wie macht man das konkret? Was heißt das? Und B, auch irgendwie, manchmal glaube ich, ist es halt echt so ein bisschen, dass noch niemand sich auf der Bundesebene hingestellt hat, in der Bundesregierung gesagt hat, so Jungs, wir machen jetzt OpenData. Und dann sitzen die ganzen Leute in der Verwaltung und sagen, habe ich jetzt eigentlich Rückendeckung, wenn ich anfangen will, anstatt dass ich auf Informationsfreiheitsanfragen mit PDF-Dokumenten antworte, dass ich auf sie mit Excel-Dateien antworte. Darf ich das?
Ja, also da ist tatsächlich dieser Punkt mit dem nötigen Druck oder sozusagen dieser Rückendeckung, wenn du dir anguckst, die Beispiele in den USA oder auch in Großbritannien, wo es in beiden Fällen, also erst in den USA, Data.gov und dann später in Großbritannien, Data.gov UK gab, die einfach sozusagen genau andersrum gesagt haben, alles muss prinzipiell erst mal veröffentlicht werden, alle Verwaltungsdaten, also alle Regierungsdaten, die wir haben.
Woher kommt da diese Idee? Ist das gesellschaftlich verankert oder?
Es gibt, glaube ich, zwei unterrichtliche Ursprünge. Bei den Amerikanern, da war es Präsident Obama, der halt einfach ins Amt gekommen ist und der sich super kompetente Berater geholt hat. Und die haben halt gesagt, wir machen jetzt Open Government. Das heißt, wir machen einen transparenteren Staat. Wir machen einen Staat, der zur Beteiligung einlädt und einen Staat, der zur Kooperation einlädt. Und auf dieser Basis haben sie dann eben gesagt, das erste, was wir machen, ist, dass wir wirklich mal sammeln, was für Informationen gibt es alles, dass wir Leute einladen, eben wirklich Apps zu entwickeln, die dann diese Informationen nutzen, die da irgendwie Dinge bauen, die erstens irgendwie unser Staatswesen transparenter machen und zweitens auch im Alltag einfach nützig sind. Und haben sie mit großem Erfolg gemacht. Also zum Beispiel Washington hat unheimlich geniale Apps von wann kommt zunächst mal die Müllabfuhr bis hin zu in wieviel Minuten fährt eigentlich dort und dort der nächste Bus. Und gleichzeitig haben sie sich dann halt wirklich sich daran gekümmert, dass die ganzen Ministerien ihre Daten freigeben. Da gibt es bis heute so eine öffentliche Hitliste, wer hat am meisten veröffentlicht, wer hat den beliebtesten Kram veröffentlicht und sowas.
Wenn es nicht funktioniert, mach einen Videospieler raus. Eigentlich ein cooler Plan.
Ich glaube der zweite Punkt, wo du gerade noch angesetzt hast, ist eigentlich, wie es dann in Großbritannien gelaufen ist. Das ist letztlich einer der sozusagen Internet Erfinder Tim Berners-Dee, der tatsächlich gefragt wurde, während er um den Wahlkampf rum, was kann ich denn machen? Von David Cameron und ihm gesagt wurde, gibt die Daten frei, mach das. Und das interessante daran ist, dass letztlich die britische Regierung nach der Wahl, die nur gewählte, das tatsächlich umgesetzt hat. Also dieser Punkt, dass die das relativ umfassend oder sehr umfassend umgesetzt hat, hat einige Leute auch ein bisschen erstaunt. Aber es ist eben dieses tatsächlich dieses von oberster Stelle und in diesem Fall wirklich top down das zu machen, sorgt zumindest erstmal für eine Art Grundklima, das in eine andere Richtung geht, also eine sehr positive Landwirtschaft.
Wir erfahren heute in dieser Sendung wundersame Dinge, Wahlversprechen, die eingehalten werden.
Ich kann es auch konzentrieren. England, ja.
Also ganz richtig schlimm ist es nicht, die Amis haben gerade das Programm übel eingeschnitten.
Ja, aber das waren die anderen. Nein, es gibt auch dazu, ähm, weil wir gerade, ich bin gerade so ein bisschen so mit, ähm, wie sagt man, ähm, Synapsenschwenks unterwegs. Es gibt zum Beispiel jetzt in Großbritannien eine Seite, wo man sehen kann, wo konkret jetzt gerade wegen der Sparpläne, wo was, ähm, eingespart wird und du ganz konkret auf einer Karte ansehen kannst. Hier und da sind bei jedem Verein so viel wird eingespart, da und das. Und du kannst da auch wieder über die Karte sehen, dann reinklicken und dich immer tiefer reinklicken und sehen, wo vor Ort sozusagen was denn jetzt gekürzt wird. Das ist sozusagen auch eine Variante, wo man transparent macht, was passiert.
Da muss man aber ganz klar auch dazu sagen, in England hat das eine ideologische Komponente. Das heißt, die haben gerade dieses neue Programm einer Big Society und Big Society heißt sozusagen ein bisschen auch Small Government. Und da gibt es halt zum einen den Gedanken, wir geben die ganzen Finanzdaten raus, weil wir dann irgendwie besser rechtfertigen können, wenn wir kürzen. Und zum anderen gibt es halt auch den Aspekt, dass man sagt, okay, wir ermöglichen dadurch, dass wir sozusagen unser Handeln transparent machen, dass Bürger mehr davon übernehmen können und dass wir dadurch weniger staatliche Funktionen zur Verfügung stellen können. Das ist was, womit ich mich persönlich nicht verbinden möchte. Aber das ist sozusagen Teil der Argumentation dort.
So funktioniert es also anderswo bei uns. Müssen wir dann noch ein bisschen arbeiten, anscheinend. Ich möchte aber das noch mal ganz genau fragen. Es gibt bei uns keine Gegner. Es gibt nicht nicht nicht so. Also jetzt vielleicht. Also wie gesagt, vielleicht einzelne Personen, aber es gibt.
Es ist eigentlich ein Sonnenschein Thema.
Es gibt sozusagen eine Verwaltungskultur und auch eine Politikkultur, die sozusagen obergringlich staatlich ausgerichtet ist. Es gibt insofern keine Gegner, aber es gibt viele Leute, die nicht in the not amused sind.
Okay, aber das meine ich zu sagen. Es geht nur darum, sozusagen die alte Struktur aufzubrechen, um das zu machen. Aber es gibt nicht sozusagen jemanden, der grundsätzlich sagt, das ist das schlimmste Kritik, die ihr habt, so nee, das haben wir bis jetzt noch nicht so gemacht.
Naja, sagen wir mal, ich bin mir da nicht sicher, wie weit das tatsächlich sozusagen passiver und aktiver Gegner schafft, wie weit die da so besteht. Also ich glaube, es ist tatsächlich auch so ein bisschen eine Alters- und Einstellungsfrage, dass ich mir vorstellen kann oder mein Eindruck auch ist, dass eine ganze Menge Leute, sagen wir über 50, da tatsächlich ganz und gar nicht im Use sind, weil sie finden, dass Leute da nicht drin rumzufuhrwerken haben, sondern dass es primäre Staatsaufgabe ist zu funktionieren und dass der Staat macht uns Wut und so weiter. Wir haben das jetzt sehr grob zusammengefasst, aber es ist auch andersherum, es ist eben in Verwaltungen, die natürlich auch so ein bisschen so einen Grund oder allen umfassenden Versorgungsanspruch haben. Das heißt, sie wollen, wenn sie an Daten stark gearbeitet haben, ist die Neigung eher dazu, noch eine hübsche Anwendung dazu entwickeln und nicht zu sagen, es ist ein Erfolg, wenn ich die Daten zur Verfügung gestellt habe und jemand anderes ganz tolle Daten Anwendungen daraus entwickelt hat.
Das ist ja auch gerne mal stolz, wie man in England gesehen hat, oder Amerika sagt so, wenn sie sich dran messen, welche öffentlichen Daten am meisten abgerufen werden, also die präsentieren ja auch mal gern, wenn sie jetzt selbst was durchgezogen haben. Aber das ist halt schon die Frage, das Argument, das am häufigsten dagegen spricht oder angeführt sind, da zusätzliche Kosten, noch mehr Verwaltungskosten, jetzt müssen wir das alles auch noch irgendwie aufbereiten, online stellen, wo man unsererseits mit relativ geringen Ansprüchen rangeht und sagt, erstmal so wie es da ist, nicht groß aufbereitet, den Rest kann man ja immer noch...
Jetzt haben wir vorhin schon ein Nebenthema gehabt, was da mit zusammenhängt, aber jetzt nicht ganz Thema ist. Das war Open Government, also eine transparent zu kontrollierende Regierung, wo Open Data eine Grundlage sein kann oder ist. Jetzt gibt es auch noch den Begriff von Open Access und da haben wir den Jakob am Telefon und der hat dazu eine Frage. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob das hier reinpasst, aber Jakob kann sie erst mal stellen. Hallo Jakob.
Ja, die Frage ist im Grunde, wie es damit aussieht mit Open Access. Also das passt ja meiner Meinung nach, gehört es ja eben dazu, zu den deutlich finanzierten Projekten.
Erklären, was Open Access ist, die Herren hier im Studio?
Ich meine, die Grundidee dabei ist, dass du sagst, Open Access ist letztlich wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse, vor allem auch die dahinter liegenden wissenschaftlichen Daten, offen zugänglich zu machen. Weil der Wissenschaftsbetrieb funktioniert ja normalerweise bei diesen Sachen genau andersrum. Ich mache eine Forschungsarbeit, ich reiche die ein, die wird dann von anderen Wissenschaftlern meist anonym bewertet. Das geht ungefähr zwei Jahre lang, dann erscheint das irgendwann in einem Fachmagazin, für das man entweder als Papierding bezahlen muss oder für das Online-Abo bezahlen muss. Und irgendwann ist das Ding dann erschienen. Dann hast du da Einsicht rein und dann können die Leute erst auch auf diese Ergebnisse, meistens in kleiner Tabellenform oder so, auch die Daten zugreifen. Die Gegenidee ist eben, dass man das kostenlos, vor allem online, zugänglich macht. Das ist die Grund-Open Access-Idee und die hat für meine Begriffe auch eine ganze Reihe von Vorteilen.
Also ich glaube, das grundsätzliche Problem ist sozusagen diese Publikationsfrage. Wo kann ich veröffentlichen, damit es mir ausreichend Reputationen gibt, damit ich im wissenschaftlichen Betrieb weiterkomme? Und diese Frage wird halt momentan über Institutionen beantwortet, also große Verlage, die diese Publikationen bereitstellen.
Beziehungsweise diese Zitationsindizes und solche Sachen, die sich eben aus vor allem besonders reputierlichen Fachmagazinen speisen. Das heißt, wenn du von dem tollsten Fachmagazin zitiert wirst, dann hast du einen höheren, wie heißt das, Citation Impact oder so, als wenn du das vielleicht bis jetzt, zumindest in dem System, online und kostenlos veröffentlicht hast.
Ich muss aber als Autor dafür sogar bezahlen und dann natürlich noch am meisten an der Stelle.
Das ist das, was mich so ein bisschen an der Open-Exist-Diskussion in Deutschland kratzt. Das ist jetzt pauschal und ich bin da nicht vollkommen drin, aber dass sie mittlerweile nur noch darüber diskutieren, wer wem wann wie viel zahlt und man gar nicht mehr drüber nachdenkt, wie man sozusagen wirklich aus diesem, aus der institutionell getragenen Reputationsfalle rauskommt.
Und dann macht so eine Redaktion wie die Nature ein Review, wo es jetzt auch nicht so den transparentesten Eindruck macht, wonach sie sozusagen das vergeben. Und es gibt ja auch schon viele Konzepte und Experimente für, wie so ein offener, transparenter Review funktionieren kann. Also ich meine, das größte Experiment heißt ja wohl Wikipedia.
Aber jetzt glaube ich, ganz viel durcheinander. Die grundlegenden Ideen ist, an der Uni wird wissenschaftlich gearbeitet, die Uni ist vom Staat bezahlt, also die Ergebnisse bitte so streuen, dass wir alles lesen können.
Genau oder zumindest, und das ist gerade zu albern, wenn man es laut ausspricht, aber dass ich zumindest als Wissenschaftler das Recht habe, meine eigenen Materialien danach noch mal weiter zu nutzen und irgendwie auf meinem Blog zu veröffentlichen.
Sagen wir mal so, man auch diese Grundidee der Online-Veröffentlichung, vor allem auch sozusagen der Art Online-Review, der vorher erfolgt. Das heißt, andere Leute können schon das Zwischenergebnis, bevor es letztlich publiziert ist, angucken, können da schon zum Beispiel auch das Ding diskutieren, sagen, das und das finde ich gut oder haben bereits einen Zugang dazu. Das ist, glaube ich, prinzipiell ziemlich schlau, weil es eben sozusagen den Zugang vieler zu viel Wissen fördert. Also auch den ganzen wissenschaftlichen Ablauf.
Aber das ist ja wahrscheinlich dann auch wieder schon der zweite Schritt. Oder wenn man es so machen würde wie beim OpenData, dass man sagt, wir nehmen erstmal was mehr kriegen können, wäre ja wahrscheinlich die Forderung, okay, irgendwie veröffentlicht, haltet euren berühmten Papers, ist uns egal, aber dann bitte stellt es auch öffentlich zur Verfügung.
Es gibt ja da auch zwei Ansätze. Das eine sozusagen sofort und ausschließlich, nur Open zu veröffentlichen oder parallel.
Was wäre denn ganz konkret eure Änderung sozusagen im Urheberrechts für eine Diplomarbeit? Also wie sollte diese behandelt werden können, vielleicht ausgedrückt in einer Creative Commons Lizenz?
Sie sollte nicht von Guttenberg zitiert werden?
Nein, also ich glaube, die Diplomarbeit ist gar nicht unser Problem. Das Problem ist halt irgendwie dieser Alltagstrott, in dem Wissenschaftler sind, die sich irgendwie ihre Sache erarbeiten wollen. Und ich glaube, es gibt noch ein zweites und etwas größeres Problem, was man vielleicht noch ansprechen kann. Das ist sozusagen die Frage von Informationen, die sozusagen ein Kernprodukt eines wissenschaftlichen Prozesses sind. Also zum Beispiel Informationen über das Genom oder Informationen über, meinetwegen sogar, synthetische Lebensformen, die wir mittlerweile schaffen. Und da die Frage, kann ich so etwas patentieren, was ja dann auch im Prinzip eine Verletzung der Idee von offenem Zugang ist? Kann ich ein neues Reißkorn, was ich irgendwo in Indien entdeckt habe, kann ich das patentieren und damit jedem anderen verbieten, das weiterzunutzen? Also das ist eine spannende Diskussion, die sich da letztendlich auch anschließt.
Jakob, sind damit deine Fragen geklärt erst mal?
Ja, ich hatte sogar mehr in die Richtung gedacht, dass auch so Rohdaten veröffentlicht werden direkt.
Also ich sag mal so, ich glaub die Rohdatenidee, das gehört auch dazu. Allerdings kannst du die natürlich nicht vor der zu sagen erst veröffentlichen, aber das gehört ganz klar zu den klassischen Open Access Forderungen, dass du sagst, die Daten sollen raus. Weil das ist ja die Idee, letztlich sozusagen die Überprüfbarkeit, die Weiterverwendung sozusagen auch zu gucken, ist da irgendwo eine Fälschung drin. Wir haben ja einiges gelernt über Fälschungen in letzter Zeit in der Wissenschaft.
Ich glaube, gerade diese Datenforderungen, die ist unheimlich wichtig, zum Beispiel auch weil es irgendwie eine Möglichkeit ist, sicherzustellen, dass viele gescheiterte Extrumente veröffentlicht werden.
Und ein weiterer Punkt ist auch sozusagen die sozusagen eine Art Naturschutz, nein, also Bestandsschutz. Das heißt nämlich, wenn einerseits irgendwie so ein Ding dann in einer Bibliothek vor sich hingammelt habe ich nichts dagegen, wenn ich eine übergeordnete große Online-Datenbank habe, die sozusagen auch öffentlich getragen wird, dann ist dafür gesorgt, dass diese Daten vielleicht auch noch 50 Jahre später zugänglich sind. Oder die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie von möglichst vielen Leuten in einem gemeinsamen Format verfügbar ist, ist damit deutlich höher.
So, jetzt haben wir es aber, oder? Alles klar. Viel Spaß noch. Ihr könnt auch weiterhin anrufen, wenn ihr OpenData habt oder haben wollt, und zwar unter dieser Nummer. 0331 70 97 110 Was ich ja gerne noch hören würde im Verlauf der Sendung, sind ein paar Erfolgsgeschichten. Also möglicherweise nicht aus Deutschland, aber möglicherweise aber auch doch. So Dinge, wo OpenData schon mal richtig gut geklappt hat, jetzt mal abgesehen von U-Bahn-Fahrplänen.
Also ich persönlich bin immer so ein bisschen begeisterungsfähig für die Dinge, die wirklich einem erklären, wie der Start funktioniert. Und da gibt es halt unheimlich viele spannende Sachen. Also eine Sache, die ich liebe, ist opencongress.org.com. Wo man einfach gucken kann, was macht der US-Congress gerade. Das gleiche gibt es auch in England, They work for you. Wo man genau gucken kann, was macht eigentlich mein MP gerade.
Und was steht da genau drin?
Da steht drin, dein MP ist 10% konservativer als normale MPs. Und hat diese und diese Position zu diesen und diesen Themen. So ein kleiner Katalog von 20 Themen und so was. Und es wurde halt erstellt im Prinzip durch Data Mining der Parlamentsreden, durch Data Mining auf die Abstimmungsergebnisse der Parlamentshäuser und so weiter und so fort.
Es gibt sozusagen eine relativ hübsche Anwendung, die auch sogar von einem öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender kommt, nämlich vom ZDF. Es gibt das Parlameter. Das ist auch eine relativ spannende Anwendung. Weil du kannst erst mal da dir angucken, also du kannst es aufschlüsseln nach Parlamentsfraktionen. Du kannst aber auch relativ weit das runterfiltern. Du kannst es bis hingehen, dass du siehst, ein einzelner Abgeordneter der FDP männlich mit überdurchschnittlich hohen Nebeneinkünften hat folgendermaßen abgestimmt oder sich enthalten. Du kannst es auf relativ viel runterbrechen und nochmal mit Teilsachen oder hat überdurchschnittlich geringe Nebeneinkünfte oder solche Geschichten.
Apropos runterbrechen. Das macht Spaß. Das Ganze kann man natürlich auch geografisch runterbrechen. Es ist irgendwie wahr, dass die interessantesten Entscheidungen auf lokaler, auf kommunaler Ebene gefällt werden. Da gibt es auch ganz spannende Projekte. Hier in Deutschland gibt es ein Projekt, das heißt Frankfurt Gestalten. Das sind ein paar Frankfurter, die sich hingesetzt haben. Frankfurt Main. Die sich hingesetzt haben, das Parlamentssystem der Stadt gescrept haben und jetzt auf eine Karte plotten, worüber der Stadtrat gerade verhandelt. Also die verhandeln gerade über eine Baustelle an der und der Straße oder über Dinge, die in dem und dem Viertel passieren. Das Gleiche gibt es zum Beispiel auch in England. Eine schöne Seite. OpenD Local. Die haben das dann zum Beispiel wieder verbunden mit wofür hat welches Council wie viel Geld ausgegeben. Auch da gibt es natürlich in England mehr Daten als bei uns. Aber auch wir haben die einzelnen Councils sich verhalten. Oder was ich auch schön finde, ist etwas wie Planning Alerts, wo man einfach eine E-Mail bekommt jedes Mal, wenn im Umkreis von 5, 10, 20, 50 cm in den eigenen Wohnort irgendwie ein Bauvorhaben aktuell wird.
Um mal nachzugucken, ob man das überhaupt will, oder?
Um einfach die Gelegenheit zu haben, sich politisch zu involvieren, bevor irgendwie die Abrissbirne kommt.
Jetzt haben wir, als wir uns vor der Zeit darüber unterhalten haben, Apropos Straßenbau, ging es auch irgendwie um so Dinge, wo man, auch in Großbritannien glaube ich, wo man irgendwie Schlaglöcher melden kann, oder sowas in der Richtung. Gehört das auch dazu?
Das ist so ein bisschen Randgebiet. Es gibt eine wunderschöne Seite FixMyStreet. Da gehe ich einfach drauf. Das gibt es auch in Deutschland in verschiedenen Varianten mittlerweile. Aber FixMyStreet ist sozusagen die ursprüngliche Idee. Ich gehe da drauf, wenn ich irgendwo ein Schlagloch sehe, wenn ich irgendwo Müll rumliegen sehe, wenn ich irgendwo sehe, dass eine Scheibe eingetreten ist oder sowas. Und kann einfach das registrieren. Und dann wird sozusagen in der Öffentlichkeit gesagt, hier guck mal, da ist ein Bericht. Und dann haben die die Behörden die Möglichkeit zu reagieren, zu sagen, okay, da haben wir jemand hingeschickt. Oder guck mal, da gibt es 20 Dinge, die sind gerade wichtiger. Dann machen wir die erstmal und dann kommt irgendwie das dran. Und das finde ich eine superschöne Sache. Das ist in dem Sinne nicht Government Data, sondern es ist eher irgendwie kollaboratives Sammeln. Man muss sich bewusst machen, dass Staaten von vornherein die größten Crowdsourcing-Organisationen sind, die wir jemals hatten. Es gibt zum Beispiel die 112. Wir hätten nicht die Möglichkeit, überall einen Feuerwehrmann hinzustellen. Aber dadurch, dass wir diesen Prozess Crowdsourcen, haben wir Feuervorsorge.
Ich mach kurz zurück, dieser FixMyStreet, aber der Teil nach der Meldung basiert doch schon auf OpenData. Also der funktioniert ja nur, wenn die Verwaltung.
Wenn der Staat transparent handelt. Genau. Oder wenn die Verwaltung. Es gibt in Deutschland ein Märkern Brandenburg, das ist ein ähnliches Projekt. Da kann man auch ganz schön gucken. Das ist auch ein Einblick in die Interessen und Stürfnisse der Bürger, die dort unterwegs sind.
Die Lebenswelten unter Umständen auch. Es sind halt wirklich die lokalste Ebene, an die du kommst. Da beschweren sich dann Leute darüber, dass Jugendliche immer ohne Helm mit Motorrädern auf irgendeiner Freifeliche rumfahren. Ihnen gefällt das nicht. Das reflektiert natürlich auch ein bisschen, wie es den Leuten da geht. Aber es ist natürlich auch einfach die klassischen Sachen. Da und dort gehen die Straßenlaternen nicht, da ist ein Schlagloch. Und du kannst dann tatsächlich sehen, wird bearbeitet oder kann gerade nicht bearbeitet werden. Und es ist dann auch grün markiert, wenn das bearbeitet ist. Und da ist eben so ein kurzer Eintrag von einem Sachbearbeiter, wenn es grün markiert ist, wurde ordnungsgemäß der Firma übergeben, die sich darum kümmert. Oder kann gerade nicht übergeben werden, weil wir erst ab April wetterbedingt Schlaglöcher auspülen.
Wie muss ich mir das vorstellen? Ist das einfach nur so eine Tabelle, wo ich irgendwie was reinschreibe? Oder ist das auch so eine schöne Karte?
Merkel Brandenburg hat durchaus eine Karte. Ich würde trotzdem sagen, dass das wahrscheinlich keine Webdesign Awards gewinnt. Aber es gibt zum Beispiel auch eine Software.
Eingabemaske ist letztlich das Wort dazu.
Okay, eine schicke Eingabemaske. Wir spielen jetzt noch ein Stück Creative Commons Musik. Vor allem Fritz Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Das hat der Michael mitgebracht. Das ist von Mild Tape. Bist du da einfach nur drüber gestolpert und hast gesehen, oh ja, könnte man mal oder gibt es da noch eine Geschichte zu?
Sagen wir mal, die Geschichte ist, dass ich eine gewisse Affinität zu Dub und Elektro-Sachen habe. Das ist aber der wesentliche Punkt dazu.
Okay, Extend of the Food. Gut, viel Spaß dabei und dann wie gesagt, nach dem FritzInfo geht's weiter.
Und jetzt kommen wir zu den Datenverkehrsmeldungen. Keine Sperrungen ohne Gesetz. Der Generalanwalt des Europäischen Gerichtshofes stellt klar, dass ohne eine gesetzliche Grundlage kein Gericht einen Internetprovider zur Sperrung einer Seite verpflichten darf. Wir empfehlen jegliche Gesetzesinitiative hierzu, etwa im Bereich des Urheber- oder Glücksspielrechts, weiträumig zu umwählen. Ägypten, das Kabinett, überarbeitet das eigene Kommunikationsrecht dahingehend, dass in einem Krisenfall die zuständigen Behörden künftig nicht mehr die Internet- und Telefonanbieter zur Abschaltung der Netze anweisen dürfen. Wir wünschen allen Datenreisenden eine angenehme Anbindung.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz-Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de fritz.de Und das Auge hört mit, man. Heute ist Chaosradio und zwar Nummer 167. Markus Richter ist hier am Start und hat drei Gäste gleich. Der eine ist der Typ, der sich gerade den Kopfhörer aufsetzt und jetzt so tut, als wäre er schon lange im Studio gewesen. Wetterfrau Schaloon, guten Abend.
Ein Abend.
Ja, wie gesagt, in der nächsten Sendung drücke ich das Mikrofon wie er selber. Er hat gesagt, er sei schon groß und könne das alleine. Ich kann nichts dafür. Außerdem ist da der Friedrich, ein Open Data Aktivist. Und dessen Mikro muss ich wieder rumhauen. Okay, so viele Runden Malmarte, die heute ausgegeben werden müssen, kann unmöglich irgendeinen Mensch trinken. Friedrich, herzlich willkommen. Und der Michael ist auch da auch ein Open Data Aktivist.
Ja, mein Mikro ist auch offen.
Open Data ist wie gesagt, Open Mic. Open Data sind die Daten, die der Staat sammelt mit unserem Geld. Und die wollen die Open Data Aktivisten öffentlich haben. Wir haben schon gerade darüber gesprochen, wie man das macht, dass der Staat das macht, was für Probleme es da gibt, was für gesetzliche Hürden, aber auch dafür Sprechungen, welche Themen man damit anfassen könnte, welche Sachen es anderswo gibt. All das könnt ihr euch nachhören, wenn ihr den Podcast, die Sendung hat, ungefähr eine Stunde später dann erscheint. Die Frage ist aber noch, Open Data gibt es doch bestimmt auch schon. Wir werden ja nicht ganz bei Null anfangen. Welche Daten werden schon veröffentlicht, die möglicherweise sinnfrei sind oder aus denen man möglicherweise mal was basteln könnte?
Also es gibt eine ganz wenige von Daten in Deutschland. Wenig. Im Prinzip gibt es hier keine Daten, die vom Staat freigegeben werden, die wirklich als Open Data lizenziert wurden. Aber es gibt zum Beispiel die Daten von der Bundesstatistik. Die liegen im Web und jeder kann sie nutzen, wenn er sie denn sozusagen die Quelle nennt. Es gibt zum Beispiel Sachen wie die Information der BaFin, wo recht viele interessante Sachen rumliegen.
Können wir kurz ein Beispiel noch sagen, also Bundesstatistik, was steht da drin?
Das ist eine riesengroße Sammlung von unterschiedlichen Sachen. Von der Bevölkerung pro Bundesland, Kinder pro Familie, wirklich diese ganzen Dinge, die man sich immer vorstellt. Import, Export, wie entwickeln sich unterschiedliche Güterklassen, bis hin zu wie entwickelt sich die Demografie. Wirklich diese ganzen Sachen. Das Problem mit den Sachen ist, dass im Prinzip alle interessanten Fragen, die man aus diesen Daten beantworten kann, beantworten die Statistiker normalerweise. Das heißt für uns als OpenData-Leute ist das eher als Füllmaterial interessant.
Das heißt aber zu sagen, das ist schon mal ein Bereich, wo das geklappt hat, wo das so gut geklappt hat, dass auch schon die Aufwertung der Daten, die Auswertung der Daten quasi geschehen ist.
Genau, also die werden von dem Bundesamt für Statistik und von den Landesämtern irgendwie bereitgestellt. Es gibt dort die Daten, es gibt diese ganz gute Regel, dass man sie benutzen darf. Das ist echt ein Paradebeispiel dafür, wie das in Deutschland aussehen kann.
Also das Statistikamt, da kann ich die Daten auch für alle anderen Zwecke, wenn ich da einmal rankomme, nutzen. Genau, das heißt es gibt leider wirklich nur diese effektiven Verwaltungskosten, dass ich da an die Daten rankomme. So eine Mitgliedschaft machen sie da ja irgendwie.
Es gibt so einen Webservice, da zahlt man im Prinzip dafür, dass man diesen Webservice nutzen darf, aber die Daten kann man zum Beispiel unter opendatalabs.org/desdatisins Web stellen.
Das wäre ja auch noch mal so eine interessante Frage, was ist denn so, zweitgleich sich eure Strategie zum einen irgendwie die Politik, den Staat dazu zu überreden, die Daten verfügbar zu machen und die andere Nummer halt einfach die Daten zu nehmen, die da sind. Und an der Stelle wäre es aber legal oder sozusagen kein Problem, wenn man sich da für einen Monat den Account holt, sich alle Daten holt und dann weitergibt. Das stinkt doch nach, habt ihr das schon gemacht?
Macht ihr das immer wieder?
Es gibt auch eine Möglichkeit, wenn man sagt, was sind denn diese offenen Daten? Wurde das jetzt bereits in Deutschland, in anderen Ländern gemacht? Es gibt hier auch ein Mitglied des Open Data Network, der da so einen ganz hübschen Showroom gemacht hat, der auch opendatashowroom.org heißt, wo du dir einfach so deutsche und internationale, europäische Daten angucken kannst und eben auch showroommäßig recht schön präsentiert.
Aber vielleicht nochmal weiter mit Daten.
Wo finde ich den? Wie finde ich den?
Das Ding heißt auch wirklich opendatashowroom.org. Da klickst du drauf und da findest du in verschiedenen Bereichen. Hübsche Daten oder Beispiele für hübsche Daten.
Jetzt haben wir hübsche Daten, wir haben auch schon Daten, die verwendet wurden. Gibt es auch Daten, die rumliegen, aus denen auch nichts gemacht wurde? Oder Daten, die es gibt und die auch ein bisschen Banane sind?
Es gibt unheimlich viel Zeug, was man findet, wo man immer nicht genau weiß, darf ich es jetzt nutzen, wie darf ich es nutzen, wann darf ich es nutzen. Ein riesen Ding ist das Portal U. Da sammeln alle Leute, die in Deutschland irgendwas mit Umwelt zu tun haben, Informationen. Umwelt ist insofern ganz interessant, weil unter der Schröder-Regierung verschiedene Gesetze erlassen wurden, die für Umwelt und auch für Verbraucher höhere Transparenzstandards vorsehen. Das heißt, da gibt es einfach bereits mehr Informationen und die sind auch mit der Technik ganz fit dabei, das ganze Zeug zu sammeln.
Oh, da hab ich auch noch so eine persönliche Neugierde, auch im Anschluss an die letzte Sendung und wo das ja gerade so aktuell ist. Es gab in der deutschen Geschichte der Kernkraft 3 oder 6.000 Störmeldungen. Letzte Sendung war ja auch schon das Thema ein bisschen, habt ihr euch damit mal beschäftigt, weil das ein heißes Eisen ist, weil jeder dieser Störfälle muss ja gemeldet werden an eine behördliche Stelle, wie verfügbar diese Daten sind?
Also sagen wir mal so, es gibt, wir hatten gerade zufälligerweise heute nochmal auf einer Mailingliste recht ausführlich eine Bestandsaufnahme über öffentliche Daten in Baden-Württemberg. Und es gibt da auch von den verschiedenen Umweltverwaltungen dort in Baden-Württemberg eine Übersicht. Du kannst dir das jetzt auch schon ganz nett angucken, du kannst da reinklicken und siehst verschiedene Messstellen im Umkreis von einem Atomkraftwerk, beispielsweise Philipsburg, und kannst es dir angucken auf einer Karte. Hier und da wird gemessen und diese Sachen, diese Daten kannst du auch dir richtig zusammensuchen und letztlich dir runterladen, auch als Excel-File oder sowas.
Auch als Archiv? Also weil es gibt so ein bundesweites Netz, aber die letzten zwei Monate, da frag ich mich dann auch immer so super.
Nee, das geht richtig. Ich hab mir das auch mal zum Spaß heute mal richtig durchgeklickt und ich konnte dafür beliebige Messpunkte bis 2009 oder so, jede erhobene dann eben in Millisievert und so weiter mir das angucken. Das kannst du einerseits einfach so als rohe Daten nehmen, du kannst es dir auch nochmal erläutert anschauen. Das sind allerdings Sachen, da ist so ein bisschen der Punkt, die sind nicht sozusagen ausdrücklich als OpenData gelabelt, sondern die sind aber offen zugänglich und du kannst sie dir runterladen.
Wir können ja noch ein bisschen weiter in die Zwieligzone gucken.
Also weil noch kurz soweit ich mich eingelesen hatte zu Radioaktivität, man ist zur Meldung verpflichtet an eine Behörde, wenn es kritisch ist, dann geht es sozusagen ans Ministerium. Aber in diesem ganzen Atomgesetz hatte ich keinen Passus wirklich gefunden, der, also klar, wenn es wirklich ein Ernstfall ist, dann muss die Öffentlichkeit informiert werden, aber der sozusagen einfach einen regulären Zugriff auf diese ganzen kleineren Zwischenfälle, wenn man das mal so milde formuliert, nicht irgendwie weiter regelt. Und ich meine, da wäre dann bestimmt wieder als nächstes der Punkt Betriebsgeheimnis oder so, was wir vorhin hatten. Also wir hatten Gegner gesucht, das kam noch im Chat der Hinweis, wenn wir Gegner suchen, dann sozusagen die Unternehmen, die mit dem Vertrag, mit dem Start in irgendeinem Vertragsverhältnis stehen, die werden sich natürlich immer dagegen sträuben, dass da irgendwelche Sachen vielleicht oder die genauen Beträge öffentlich gemacht werden. Das heißt, eigentlich muss man jetzt ja schon Gesetzesinitiativen ergreifen, die da so einen Umdenken in welche Richtung...
Genau, es gibt ja in Deutschland dieses Umweltinformationsgesetz. Insofern würde ich fast sagen, dass du gute Chancen hättest, an Stratungsdaten ranzukommen, sofern sie noch nicht öffentlich sind. Gleichzeitig gibt es eben Verbraucherinformationsgesetz und es gibt das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, womit man sozusagen beliebige Informationen anfragen kann. Es gibt jetzt von Greenpeace so den ganz sinnvollen Vorstoß, dass man diese drei Dinge in einem Ding zusammenfasst, weil einfach die Transparenzgesetze ziemlich intransparent sind. Man weiß einfach nicht, vielleicht klingt es ja eigentlich ganz wunderbar.
Drei Gesetze, die mir frei garantieren. In den USA läuft es ja von der Philosophie hier seit jeher ganz anders. Da gibt es ja den Grundsatz, dass alle Werke, die der Staat schafft, grundsätzlich unter Public Domain stehen. Ist so ein bisschen wie das, was wir am Anfang der Sendung auch kurz referenziert haben, das im deutschen Urheberrechtsgesetz ja steht. Dieses Urheberrechtsgesetz trifft nicht auf Werke, die der Staat schöpft. Was dann stattdessen greift, steht da wohl irgendwie nicht so ausfindig. An der Stelle in den USA ist es halt wohl irgendwo ziemlich prominent aufgehangen im Gesetzeswesen, dass alles, was der Staat macht, so frei ist, dass man nicht mal den Namen nennen braucht. Ich kann irgendwie als Autofirma dahergehen, mir ein Foto von der NASA vom Hubble Teleskop nehmen und sagen hier Star Galaxy, das neue Auto, und damit irgendwie Werbeplakate drucken und muss niemanden irgendwie was dafür geben und nicht mal sagen, dass ihr das Foto von der NASA habt. Und das gilt da irgendwie so grundsätzlich für alles. Und dieses Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, das wir in Deutschland bekommen hatten, ist ja immer so, du kannst fragen. Mehr sagt es ja im Kern auch erstmal nicht. So grundsätzlich muss es verfügbar sein. Dir muss ein Aufwand berechnet werden können, wenn es einen so als Gebühr, wenn es einen erfordert. Aber so recht irgendwie die Aktenordner eingescannt und online gepackt haben sie ja deswegen nicht.
Sagen wir mal, der Punkt ist ja sozusagen, ich weiß nicht, könnte man das auch in einer gewissen Weise als eine Art Opt-in und Opt-out nennen. Du hast das Recht, dass du diese Informationsfreiheitsanfrage stellen kannst. Und die Stelle auf der anderen Seite muss dir diese Information stellen. Aber es ist erstmal nicht definiert, die müssen von sich aus erstmal alles zur Verfügung stellen. Und du hast die Daten damit schon. Das ist ein bisschen das Grundding im Moment bei der Informationsfreiheit in Deutschland.
Da kann man gleich dann fragen, wenn man das Zeug ohnehin freigeben muss, warum stellt man das nicht auf irgendeine Webseite? Und zum anderen ist natürlich das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz auch irgendwie leider so ein bisschen löchrig. Das heißt, es gibt viele Ausnahmen, es gibt sozusagen die Bedingungen, dass eben keine laufenden politischen Prozesse betroffen sein dürfen, keine Geschäftsgeheimnisse und natürlich Dinge, die wir auch beibehalten wollen. Also Sicherheit, öffentliche Sicherheit und Datenschutz.
Aber macht man da nicht dann der Argumentation Tür und Tor auf, ah ja, all die bösen Terroristen, können wir euch leider nicht sagen?
Ich glaube, ich hab noch ehrlich gesagt sehr sehr selten bisher Daten gefunden, bei denen man sinnvoll argumentieren konnte, dass die nun dem Terrorismus die Tür öffnen.
Na ja klar, die haben CDL nicht gezeigt. Nein, was ich meine zu sagen, ob das dann nicht als Feigenbettchen benutzt wird. Dass man sagt, ah na, das betrifft aber die Sicherheit. Oder wo ist CDL ein Punkt? Also wer darf das denn entscheiden, dass die Daten nicht...
Momentan passiert das halt in den Behörden. Und das ist so ein Prozess, den man in die Öffentlichkeitsherren muss, glaube ich.
Das ist aber schwierig, weil an irgendeiner Stelle musst du in einer Vertrauensbasis... Weil die Behörde kann ja schlecht sagen, du darfst jetzt diese Daten nicht sehen, weil... Weil mit der Begründung weißt du ja schon wieder...
Das Problem ist ein bisschen oder der Punkt, wie es jetzt läuft, ist, dass häufig tatsächlich bei Informationsfreiheitsgesetzanfragen einfach sozusagen das ganze Ding nicht veröffentlicht wird in Einzelfällen, weil es heißt, darf nicht. Die andere Variante wäre ja, einzelne Passagen zu schwärzen und das dann zu veröffentlichen.
Gerade in PDF-Dokumenten sind damit ja viele positive Erfahrungen gemacht worden in letzter Zeit.
Ja, insgesamt ist es mit dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, dass das jetzt dann überarbeitet wird. Weil es ist, glaube ich, fünf Jahre ziemlich genau her, seitdem das in Kraft getreten ist. Und das muss jetzt überarbeitet werden. Insofern sind wir hier an einem ganz interessanten Punkt, wo man sagen kann, okay, wie wollen wir das in Zukunft haben?
Gleichzeitig gibt es wieder mal England. Ja, es gibt sozusagen einen super Prozess, den man machen kann, dass man die Anfrage, die man gestellt hat, ins Web stellt. Es gibt eine Seite www.whatdothenow.com und da wird dann einfach auch die Antwort veröffentlicht. Das heißt, wenn da keine Antwort erfolgt, dann ist das eben wenigstens öffentlich dokumentiert. Und wenn da bereits eine Antwort erfolgt ist, dann kann auch jemand anderes, der die gleiche Antwort will, da schneller dran kommen. Das ist so was, was es in Deutschland auch sehr weit geben wird.
Nämlich wann, wo, wie, was? Ah, das ist aber nicht sehr transparent.
Das klingt nicht von Seiten dem Staat aufgezogen.
Na schön, wer sind denn eigentlich so die nächsten Zukunftspläne? Was macht ihr morgen und was macht ihr in fünf Jahren?
Gerade, ich persönlich bastle am offenen Parlament.
Das heißt was?
Das ist der Bundestag und der Bundesrat und das Europäische Parlament. Unterlagen, mich interessiert dabei sozusagen, wie sieht die politische Agenda gerade wirklich aus, wenn man sie runterbricht auf Zahlen, womit setzen sie sich Tag für Tag auseinander, womit setzt sich welche Ausschüsse auseinander und so weiter und so fort.
Du schaust dir gerade diese grausamen Suchmasken und Interfaces von diesen ganzen EU-Dokumentsbibliotheken an.
Die haben die großartigsten Suchmasken. Ich wusste nicht, dass man so viele Formfelder auf eine einzige Webseite packen kann.
Was vielleicht in vor fünf Jahren passiert ist, gerade jetzt in Berlin ein bisschen dafür zu sorgen, dass mehr Daten rauskommen. Und das ist auch gerade diese Probleme, die es in den letzten zwei Jahren gab. Nämlich, diese Dinger sind urheberrechtlich oder auch wirtschaftsrechtlich geschützt, sich da in eine Richtung zu bewegen, dass da mehr rauskommt. Das ist, glaube ich, mehr so die kurzfristigere Agenda.
Und dann muss man sagen, gibt es mittlerweile auch beim Bundesministerium des Inneren eine Abteilung, die sich sozusagen mit Open Government auseinandersetzen soll. Und die sind gerade dabei, sozusagen eine Koalition der Willigen zu schmieden. Das sind sowohl Ministerien wie Bundesländer, die sich eben daran beteiligen wollen, Daten rauszugeben. Das heißt, da will man dann auch in einiger Zukunft einen Datenkatalog veröffentlichen und damit eben nachziehen. Das ist aber bisher noch ein wenig in den Kinderchulen, aber da sind Leute dran und die kümmern sich und die wollen.
Ich glaube, man kann auch sagen, die arbeiten daran sozusagen Schritt für Schritt auch irgendwie den Zugang zu diesen ganzen Daten zu bieten. Die haben, sagen wir mal, das Ganze malt auch relativ langsam. Ich glaube, ich spreche hier keine Geheimnisse aus, wenn das im Moment ein Ziel ist für so eine zentrale Dateneinstiegsseite, die vom Bund getragen wird oder in dem Fall vom Bundesinnenministerium, dass die 2013 in der ersten Form da sein soll. Also das ist jetzt nicht übermorgen.
Das Problem ist, die haben halt keine ganz klar formuliertes Mandat, sondern die könnten gut ein bisschen Rückendecken brauchen.
Was die Statistikseite machen kann, haben wir dann jetzt geklärt. Wie ist es eigentlich auf der User-Seite? Also ich meine, ihr setzt euch dafür ein, ihr seid jetzt zwei dort, ihr habt noch einen Verein, da gibt es noch ein paar. Kann, soll, darf die Bevölkerung, wir alle vom Neuartigen Rundfunkumfangsgerät, gerade da irgendwas dran machen und wenn ja was?
Ich glaube, da gibt es ganz viele Dinge, die man machen kann. Also natürlich jeder, der in der Lage ist, ein bisschen Code zu schreiben, sollte das tun und sollte dabei interessante Dinge zeigen und uns helfen zu verstehen oder uns alltäglich Probleme lösen damit.
Das war ganz nur ein Aspekt mit dem Codeschreiben. Also es geht nicht ausschließlich um die Hacker, sondern es geht einfach auch um Leute, die sich interessieren. Die können natürlich einerseits sagen, ja, Open Data Networks zum Beispiel, ja, würde ich gerne mitmachen. Es ist ein Aspekt, aber auch ein anderer Aspekt ist zu sagen, selbst nachzufragen bei einer Behörde, haben sie da nicht Daten? Einfach mal anzurufen und zu fragen und zu sagen, da muss es doch was geben. Wo lagert das denn bei ihnen und ist das eigentlich schon zugänglich oder würden sie das gerne zugänglich machen? Planen sie das zugänglich zu machen? Solche Fragen kann man als Bürger stellen. Also da muss man kein Hacker sein.
Ich denke auch, das muss man einfach mehrfach tun, da so einen öffentlichen Druck sozusagen erzeugen.
Oder einfach nur eine Warnhebung.
Wenn sozusagen alle Behörden sagen, ja mei, eigentlich hätte ich auch nichts dagegen, ich darf es nur gerade nicht, ich hab nur keine Gesetzesgrundlage, dann halt auch bei den Politikern zu landen. Und wenn halt der Themenpolitiker zu einem jeweiligen Thema sagt, ja mei, ich wüsste jetzt auch nicht warum, so und es dann von allen Parteien kommt, dann kann man das ja auch mal so orientiert präsentieren und sagen, hey, eigentlich habt ihr alle nichts dagegen, ihr tut es nur nicht. Und dann ist halt wirklich die Frage, wo passiert dann was?
Aber gibt es, gilt es auch noch sozusagen, so eine Art Bedürfnis zu wecken? Also ich nehme jetzt mal als wirklich hinkendes Beispiel aber mal dieses Privatsphäre-Ding. Da gibt es irgendwie viele Aktivisten, aber ein Großteil der Bevölkerung versteht einfach nicht, wozu soll das überhaupt gut sein? Also gibt es ein öffentliches Interesse an OpenData? Oder muss da auch noch was passieren?
Ich glaube, wir haben einfach noch zu wenig Dinge, die jetzt in Deutschland konkret da sind, die auch irgendwie eine große Öffentlichkeit erreicht haben, wo man dann sagen kann, okay, das hat uns irgendwie geholfen, irgendwas besser zu tun. Also insofern ist da schon auch der Aufruf da gleichzeitig. Ich glaube, dass da auch einfach der Staat teilweise auch in Vorleistung gehen muss und sagen muss, okay, wir machen jetzt hier, wir laden jetzt dazu ein. Wenn das immer sozusagen so eine halbe Konteraktion ist, dann ist es kein Wunder, dass das irgendwie irgendwann attraktiver ist zu liegen, sondern man muss da glaube ich, ja, auf der statischen Seite.
Also sag mal, glaube ich, um viele Leute zu mobilisieren, brauchst du ein Aufregerthema. Wir hatten ja auch wieder ein britisches Beispiel, da gab es so diese ganzen...
Die Briten, man, können nicht kochen, aber OpenData, geil!
Nee, ich meine, sie können auch vor allem richtig tolle Nebeneinkünfte, seltsame Nebeneinkünfte haben. Und da gab es diesen Parliament Spending Scando, wo dann der Guardian rangegangen ist. War das der Guardian? Ich glaube schon, ne? Und gesagt hat, wir haben hier eine ganze Menge Daten. Liebe User, macht da mal mit und ordnet das mal zu, guckt euch das mal an und dann konnte man auch immer mit einen hübschen Verlaufsbalken sehen auf deren Website. Okay, jetzt sind schon 7%, irgendwann waren es da 87% oder sowas. Alle schon verifiziert und zugeordnet. Das heißt, da hast du relativ viele Leute sensibilisiert für das ganze Thema. Sie haben gesehen, okay, das ist ein Aufreger für mich und haben da mitgemacht. Und da hast du dann auch irgendwann gesehen, okay, das ist jetzt open.
So, liebe Politiker, ihr dürft das nächste halbe Jahr Parteispenden annehmen, damit wir im übernächsten halben Jahr einen Skandal haben, damit wir dann OpenData an den Start bringen können. Jetzt ist ja manchmal so, dass die Gäste dieser Sendung sagen, zwei Stunden, viel zu kurz, um Gottes willen. Wir haben jetzt noch drei Minuten. Was haben wir vergessen?
Ich wollte noch fragen, habt ihr Projekte aus Berlin und Brandenburg? Oder Visualisierung, Darstellung?
Wir hatten eine...
Oder was macht der Staat in Berlin-Brandenburg? Genau.
Also was macht der Staat in Berlin-Brandenburg? Es gibt eben diese Initiative, die jetzt zusammen mit Leuten aus der Zivilgesellschaft und mit Leuten aus der Verwaltung Politik versucht, in Berlin das konkret umzusetzen. Es gibt einiges an Bewegungen in den Senatsverwaltungen, wo man überlegt, können wir, wollen wir, wann? Und da sind auch Leute dran, die das tun. Ich glaube, was denen auch weiterhelfen wird, ist, wenn von außen die Frage kommt und wenn man das auch im Wahlkampf zum Thema macht natürlich. Die Frage, wie wird in Zukunft in Berlin regiert? Wird da irgendwie transparent regiert oder wird da irgendwie hinter verschlossenen Türen gemacht?
Tatsächlich wäre natürlich so eine Ansage noch, während der Bürgermeister ist, ich veröffentliche alle Daten und das ist auch gut so. Ich glaube, diese Rückendeckung würde helfen.
Könnt ihr noch mal auf dieses Netzwerk, was ihr sagt, referenzieren, was sich da sozusagen auftut und diesen Termin, den du nanntest, am 18. Mai glaube ich, kann man da hinkommen? Ist das offen?
Da kann man hinkommen, aber ist leider voll.
Das ganze Ding heißt Berlin Open Data Day, hat einen etwas interessanten Namen Body. Das ganze Netzwerk von uns ist das Open Data Network.
Und es gibt jetzt auch zunehmend mal wieder die Bestrebung, ein paar Hackdays abzuhalten. Ich hab jetzt gerade den aktuellen Termin, ich glaube, das ist der 17. Mai. Da wird es einen Hackday, soweit ich weiß, geben zur Frage von Verkehrs.
Leute, die in diese Sendung kommen. Nee, Termin hab ich nicht im Kopf, aber ihr könnt es auf der Webseite nachschalten.
Nein, es ist der 14. Mai, weil das ist ein Samstag. 14. Mai ist ein Samstag, 18. Mai ist ein Mittwoch, an dem dieser Body stattfindet. Und der Hackday ist an dem Wochenende davor, damit die Leute, die verschiedenen Sachen nachgehen, unter der Woche vielleicht noch da ein bisschen was marken.
In der Seabase findet das statt.
Da wollte ich auch noch gleich hin.
Apropos wo gleich hin, wir sind dann gleich mal weg. Ich danke euch auf jeden Fall fürs dabei gewesen sein. Für die OpenDatas, die wir heute erfahren haben. Vielleicht werden es ein bisschen mehr in Zukunft. Viel Spaß. Wir hören uns früher wieder aber in dieser Form, also im Chaosradio, dann wieder in einem Monat, am letzten Donnerstag im Monat. Den Podcast dieser Sendung, den gibt es ganz, ganz, ganz gleich. Also im Laufe der Nacht noch auf fritz.de. Später dann auch auf chaosradio.de. Da könnt ihr auch noch reichhaltig kommentieren. Dann gibt es einen Blog zur Sendung, einen Wiki, falls ihr Fragen habt oder Kommentare, könnt ihr das da alles reintragen. Damit sind wir eigentlich raus. Nach uns kommt, oder nein, doch nicht. Da ruht noch jemand tief Luftbedeutungsschwanger? Nein, alles gesagt, ausnahmsweise mal in zwei Stunden. Nach uns kommt Flo Heiler mit dem Night Flight. Wird euch Punk-Musik auf die Ohren werfen, bis sie bluten. Vorher aber noch, natürlich, wie immer, am Ende dieser Sendung ein Titel, der mir und euch sehr ans Herz gewachsen ist. Website mit Dragan Espenschied von Trekkie Birthday. Und mir bleibt da nur noch eins zu sagen. Vielen Dank euch und lasst euch nicht überwachen. Und macht immer schön eure Backups.